this thirteen point Cavalier lead their
largest of the series Mars throws event
Baines goes inside blocked by James
right at the rim has the big veins that
shout out of him hey Ron he has had some
classic blocks
Tatom forces up the shot knocks it down
ten points now for Jason Tatum backdoor
James throws it down perfect bounce pass
from Kevin Love and it's back up to 20
this type of dunk would take a lot out
of me also Mike spectacular past mile of
the big-time finished by LeBron James
mama there goes that man Adam fakes
Rozier drives and throws it down as high
as 26 high speed hits sign again he has
had some magnificent passes tonight
that's his ninth assistants keeping his
dribble and then just a beautiful left
hand wraparound feet Jayde's throws it
up but Nance throws it down
another assist for LeBron James his 11th
of the game you want to get beat 40 give
them all the ammunition Eastern
Conference final is now two games to one
in favor of the Celtics
[Applause]
impressive
bounce back win and much-needed win for
the Cavaliers